>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD, EARLY
VOTING IS UNDERWAY IN TEXAS FOR
THEIR MARCH 1st PRIMARY
ELECTION.
WE'RE SEEING EARLY SPINES THE
LONE STAR STATE IS NOT
SUCCEEDING IN ADDITION TO
ALREADY RESTRICTIVE MAIL-IN
BALLOTS, THE NEW LAW REQUIRES
VOTERS TO REMEMBER INFORMATION
FROM DECADES AGO.
THAT HAS RESULTED IN A SLEW OF
REJECTED BALLOTS, INCLUDING THAT
OF A WORLD WAR II VETERAN.
>> I'M ANGRY.
>> Reporter: AFTER DECADES OF
HELPING OTHERS TO VOTE, A NEW
ELECTION LAW LAND 74-YEAR-OLD
PAM GASKIN IN UNFAMILIAR
TERRITORY.
HER BALLOT WAS REJECTED NOT ONCE
BUT TWICE.
>> I AM PAM GASKIN.
SUPER VOTER.
>> Reporter: FIRST, THE COUNTY
HAD YET TO UPDATE, WHICH NOW
REQUIRES VOTERS TO ADD THEIR
TEXAS DRIVERS LICENSE OR PARTIAL
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER TO THE
APPLICATION.
WHICH IS WHAT SHE DID IN HER
SECOND ATTEMPT BUST THERE'S A
CATCH.
>> THE LAW SAYS IT HAS TO BE THE
NUMBER THAT WAS ON YOUR
APPLICATION WHEN YOU REGISTERED
TO VOTE.
>> WHEN DID YOU REGISTER TO
VOTE?
46 YEARS AGO.
>> BECAUSE SHE WROTE HER VALID
LICENSE NUMBER BUT HAD
REGISTERED WITH HER SOCIAL, IT
WAS REJECTED.
>> PEOPLE WON'T VOTE.
>> THE 94-YEAR-OLD VETERAN'S
BALLOT APPLICATION WAS DENIED
TWICE.
IN 1940s HARRIS COUNTY, HE
DIDN'T USE EITHER NUMBER TO
REGISTER SO NO MATCH.
IN TEXAS, ONLY A PERSON OVER 65,
DISABLED OR OUT OF THE COUNTY
CAN VOTE BY MAIL.
BUT DAYS BEFORE THE APPLICATION
DEADLINE, THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
REJECTIONS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE, ALL POLITICAL PARTIES,
AND THIS ISN'T THE ONLY PROBLEM.
A TIGHT TIME LINE TO IMPLEMENT
CHANGES MEANS LESS TRAINING IN
VOTER EDUCATION.
14% OF MAIL-IN BALLOTS HAVE BEEN
REJECTED OVER I.D. ISSUES SO
FAR.
>> WE'RE STILL GETTING EMAILS ON
ALL THESE TWEAKS IN THE LAWS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A HIGHER
THAN USUAL, ALMOST DOUBLE NUMBER
OF REJECTION OF MAIL BALLOTS.
>> Reporter: BUT NOW THE BALLOTS
ARE ALSO BEING FLAGGED AND
RETURNED ACROSS THE STATE.
NEARLY 40% SO FAR IN HARRIS
COUNTY.
OVERWHELMINGLY DUE TO THE NEW
I.D. REQUIREMENTS, WHICH VOTERS
NEED TO WRITE AGAIN IN A SPACE
UNDER THE FLAP ON THE EXTERNAL
BALLOT RETURN ENVELOPE.
THERE'S SO MUCH CONFUSION.
SHE'S DOUBLE STAFFING AT PHONE
BANKS.
>> WE GOT 8,000 CALLS IN JANUARY
ALONE.
5,000 OF WHICH WERE ABOUT MAIL
BALLOT VOTING.
>> Reporter: TEXAS IS ONE OF 19
STATES THAT PASSED RESTRICTIVE
VOTING LEGISLATION IN 2021.
>> NOW LET'S MAKE THIS
IDENTIFIABLE.
>> Reporter: BEFORE GREG ABBOTT
SIGNED IT INTO LAW LATE LAST
YEAR, ACTIVISTS WARNED ABOUT
POTENTIAL SNARES LIKE I.D. MATCH
AND COMPLICATED ENVELOPES.
>> THE CHALLENGES WE'RE SEEING
NOW ARE A FUTURE OF SB 1, OF THE
VOTING LAW.
>> Reporter: THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE TELLING CNN IN A
STATEMENT, OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
WORKING AS QUICKLY AND
DILIGENTLY FOR OFFICIALS AND
VOTE ORDERS CHANGES TO THE
VOTING PROCESS IN TEXAS.
FOR GASKIN, THE LONG JOURNEY IS
ALMOST COMPLETE.
AN ONLINE BALLOT TRACKER NOW
REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW SAYS HERS
HAS BEEN RECEIVED.
>> 28 DAYS.
THREE ATTEMPTS.
SUCCESS.
WHAT WORRIES ME IS THAT
EVERYBODY IS NOT AS TENACIOUS AS
I AM.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO 66 WITH IT.
>> Reporter: NOW, THERE IS A LOT
OF ATTENTION ON THE MAIL BALLOT
PART OF THIS.
BUT EARLY IN-PERSON VOTING
STARTED THIS WEEK IN TEXAS.
AND ACTIVISTS ARE WATCHING
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THAT NEW
LAW.
THAT'S THE FURTHER EMPOWERMENT
AND ACCESS FOR THOSE PARTISAN
POLL WATCHERS.
IT IS SOMETHING ELSE THEY
TESTIFIED LEADING UP TO THE LAW
BEING PASSED SAYING THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT INTIMIDATION,
ESPECIALLY IN THIS EXCEPTIONALLY
CHARGED CLIMATE WE'VE BEEN
LIVING IN IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
>> THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
S.E. KUPP, YOU JUST HEARD, THREE
ATTEMPTS ON SEND IN A BALLOT.
28 DAYS.
I WOULD SAY THE LAW DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE WORKING BUT MAYBE
IT IS WORKING EXACTLY AS
INTENDED.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS BY DESIGN.
THIS IS NOT COMPLICATED.
THIS IS WHAT THE POINT WAS FOR
REPUBLICANS WHO WANTED TO GUM UP
THE SYSTEM AND MAKE VOTING
HARDER.
WHEN YOU WANT TO MAKE IT HARDER,
YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO VOTE.
YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO VOTE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO
VOTE FOR THE OTHER GUY.
I DON'T WANT TO SOUND DRAMATIC
BUT FASCISM HAS THE SAME GOAL.
FASCISM BANS PARTIES TO ACHIEVE
THE SAME OUTCOME.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT A FASCIST
GOVERNMENT BUT THIS IS A
WORK-AROUND TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
TO VOTE.
AND THAT'S FRANKLY WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU'RE OUT OF IDEAS.
WHEN YOU KNOW, LIMITING
DEMOCRACY AND ACCESS TO VOTING
IS ALL YOU'RE BRINGING TO THE
TABLE, AS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU'RE JUST OUT OF IDEAS.
>> YOU'RE IN SOUTH CAROLINA
WHERE YOU MUST HAVE SEEN A LOT
OF THAT.
PEOPLE TRYING TO MAKE IT TOUGHER
TO VOTE.
>> THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH, I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE TO GO TO FASCISM,
ALTHOUGH SHE IS RIGHT ABOUT WHAT
IT IS.
OLD-FASHIONED RACISM.
IT HASN'T BEEN THAT LONG AGO
WHERE WE HAD LAWS THAT WERE
PASSED WHICH PREVENTED PEOPLE OF
COLOR, THE ELDERLY, THE ILL
POFRISHED FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
THE BALLOT BOX.
THE '40s, '50s, THE EARLY PART
OF THE '60s.
THINGS THAT JOHN ROBERTS BEGAN
TO GUT AND THEN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THIS NEW AGE REPUBLICAN
PARTY SET AFLAME TO THE
REMAINING PART OF THE VOTING
RIGHTS PART.
THIS IS NOT A BUG.
THIS IS A FEATURE.
THIS IS WHAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, PARTICULARLY SOUTHERN
LEGISLATURES, WANT TO DO.
IT IS RACIST ON ITS FACE.
IT IS ANTI-DMATH DEMOCRATIC AND
UNAMERICAN.
WE HAVE TO CALL IT OUT AS SUCH.
THE FRUSTRATING PART FOR ME,
SITTING BEFORE YOU, THESE ARE
THE SAME BATTLES MAY FATHER
FOUGHT.
HERE I AM, 30 YEARS LATER AFTER
MY DAD, STILL FIGHTING THE
BATTLES.
YOU COUPLE THAT WITH SINEMA AND
MANCHIN, THEY DON'T CARE.
A LOT OF BLACK VOTERS ARE GOING
TO SUFFER FROM EXHAUSTION, THROW
THEIR HANDS UP AND SAY I'LL
TIRED OF JUMPING OVER THESE
HURDLES.
>> CNN PROJECTS THREE SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN PUSHED OUT BY VOTERS
ON TUESDAY AFTER THAT NASTY
RECALL FIGHT THAT PITTED
DEMOCRATS AGAINST DEMOCRATS.
PARENTS AT THE BORDER WERE TOO
FOCUSED ON RENAMING SCHOOLS,
INSTEAD OF REOPENING SCHOOLS.
DO YOU THINK THIS SHOULD SERVE
AS A WAKE-UP CALL TO DEMOCRATS
ABOUT THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
FACING SO MANY PARENTS AND THAT
IS, CAN THEIR KIDS GET AN
EDUCATION?
>> YEAH.
EXCUSE ME.
I HAVE A TICKLE.
COVID, COVID REALLY DID BREAK ON
PARTY LINES IN A LOT OF WAYS.
ESPECIALLY ON MASKS AND
VACCINES.
BUT IN ONE WAY, IT WAS A BRIDGE
BETWEEN THE PARTIES AND THAT'S
WHERE SCHOOLS WERE CONCERNED.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PARENTS
WOKE UP BECAUSE OF COVID.
AND WHEN IT CAME TO WHETHER, YOU
KNOW, VIRGINIA OR SAN FRANCISCO,
I MEAN, THESE WEREN'T TRUMP
VOTERS AND FOX NEWS VIEWERS
COMING FOR SUDDENLY SCHOOL
BOARDS AND TEACHERS UNIONS, AND
DEMOCRATS, THIS WAS NORTHERN
VIRGINIA DECIDING THAT TERRY
McAULIFFE DIDN'T GET IT.
AND THIS WAS RADICAL SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE THERE ARE MORE
DOGS THAN KIDS, FRANKLY, TELLING
PROGRESSIVES IN SAN FRANCISCO,
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THE MURALS
AND THE BUILDING NAMES.
WE WANT OUR KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL
SAFELY AND GETTING A GOOD
EDUCATION.
SO I THINK PARENTS HAVE REALLY
WOKEN UP.
AND I THINK THAT NEEDS TO WAKE
DEMOCRATS UP.
I THINK DEMOCRATS LONG FELT AS
IF THEY WERE THE PARTY OF
PARENTS.
AND I THINK IT TOOK A LOT OF
VOTER FOR GRANTED ON THOSE
LINES.
AND I THINK PARENTS ARE TAKING
BACK THE AUTONOMY AND THE
CONTROL THAT I THINK THEY HAVE
SURRENDERED FOR A VERY LONG TIME
TO POLITICS.
>> BACARRI, YOUR RESPONSE?
>> SHE'S RIGHT.
IF YOU RECALL ON STATE OF UNION
ON SUNDAY, HILLARY ROSEN USED
THE TERM, PARENTAL EXHAUSTION.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
DEMOCRATS HAVEN'T TAPPED INTO
THAT FRUSTRATION.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND OR DON'T GET
PRESENTAL EXHAUSTION THAT HAS
COME ALONG WITH COVID.
SO IT IS A LESSON THAT TERRY
McAULIFFE HAD TO LEARN, OR
YOU'RE IN SAN FRANCISCO, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
GOTTEN RIGHT.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY, I DON'T WANT
TO SAY LISTENED TO PARENT BUT
THEY'VE GOTTEN OUT OF THE WAY OF
PARENTS AND THEY'VE MOBILIZED,
AND PARENTS ARE MOBILIZED MORE
THAN THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
SO YES.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO STOP TALKING
AS MUCH ON COVID AND BEGIN TO
LISTEN.
I UNDERSTAND AND BELIEVE IN
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
I UNDERSTAND THE NECESSITY OF
VACCINES AND MANDATES.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A HUMAN COME
BE OPPONENT